in the past four years two and a half
million people have left the Democratic
and Republican parties hi I'm Nicolas
tree with reason TV and today i'm
talking with linda Killian author of the
swing vote the untapped power of
independence blended thanks for joining
us thank you most polls are must serve a
show about forty percent of American
voters are independent define what that
is and then talk about the real
independence within the independent sure
forty percent classify themselves
they're not Democrats they're not
Republicans they're unenrolled some
states call them undeclared unaffiliated
in the past four years two and a half
million people have left the Democratic
and Republican parties to become
independence they're really sick of the
two parties yeah talk about what's
driving the exodus from you know from
either the democratic or republican
parties which I mean have been around
since before the Civil War so this is
you know these are kind of tired brands
or organizations but why are people
leaving in such I think it's the
nonsense that's going on in Washington
the dysfunction the polarization the
influence of money in politics the
inability to to balance the budget the
inability to get something reasonable
done here let me stop for a second
because you know they're there seemed to
be a couple things going on so people
don't like the dysfunction they don't
like to see say a budget not even being
past but is that because they want to
cut the deficit or you know other you
know large pieces of legislation have
been done in the past few years whether
it was the tarp bailout or the stimulus
was passed health care reform a couple
of wars have been waged so what is it
about the dysfunction that's getting in
the way people just saying hey you know
a pox on both your head well to take
healthcare for example that was passed
on a totally partisan basis without a
single Republican vote and independent
voters didn't like that that seemed like
too much government for them if you poll
on individual pieces of health care they
actually pull pretty well but when you
ask people about the whole government
program
just seems like too much government do
independence care about govern the level
of government spending and deficits I
think they care more about sanity and
spending money wisely now they do care
about the deficit that's the second
thing they care about after the economy
so there's twenty percent or so of true
independence people who are not it you
know recovering Democrats or Republicans
these are people who whose votes are
really up for grabs it's about twenty
percent of all voters of all voters
swing change their minds vote for
Democrats and then Republicans vote for
libertarians if they're available and
these are these are the people who
decide national I think so okay and how
do we know that well if you look at for
example barack obama carried
independence by about two points in
swing states i focus on colorado Ohio
Virginia and New Hampshire obviously you
can add Florida and North Carolina to
that mix the swing voters make the
difference you can't you know
Mississippi in New York State we're not
worrying about who's carrying them we
know so in these swing states that you
have to win to get the electoral votes
you've got to get the swing voters what
are the things that are most important
to them and how do you appeal today well
it changes because the whole thing about
independent voters is they're not
dogmatic so they voted for Barack Obama
they voted for the Democrats in 2006
they swung 19 points in voting for the
Republicans in 2010 because they didn't
like the way the Democrats were running
the government they're very concerned
about the economy in this election
they're concerned about the deficit you
talk a lot in the book about how you
know centrist voters or independent
voters tend to be kind of economically
conservative and socially liberal now to
to my years that sounds like crypto
libertarians what's the overlap between
independent voters and libertarian ideas
I think that's a really good question
and I think socially tolerant fiscally
responsible is another way to say that I
think because sometimes the independent
voters were bail from being labeled you
know they don't even like to be called
centrist because they feel like they
pick and choose that you know they agree
with the Republican Party on some things
maybe defense they agree with the
Democratic Party on social issues so I
think there is overlap between
independent voters swing voters and
libertarians I think they shy away from
calling themselves libertarians in large
numbers and you said they're not
dogmatic they're not ideological errors
right they're not at all no they're not
why are the parties so we're missing
actually tapping into what actual voters
care about because they don't really see
it as being necessary especially at the
Congressional level because I talked
about redistricting reform 435 House
districts in the country most of those
are safe seats for example 2010 we had
what we consider a wave election fewer
than fifteen percent of all seeds turned
over these districts the Republican and
Democratic parties have a stranglehold
on this process they they rigged you
know public doesn't even get to testify
and so they don't have to appeal to the
center to win their seats now when
you're running statewide you do to a
certain extent but again they go back to
their party base to their fundraisers to
their leaders and they don't just feel
that the voters are that important or
that's smart or I don't know and I think
that's why so many voters are
disaffected they told me I would hold
focus groups in Ohio and Colorado New
Hampshire I heard the same thing they
don't think people are listening they
don't think their voice matters they
don't think the politicians really care
what they want and think and this is why
the approval rating of Congress is in
the single digit mean that's a sign of
great intelligence among the American
electorate isn't it I want to thank
Linda Killian author of the swing vote
the untapped power of Independence
speaking with reason TV thanks Linda
thank you
you